ich habe übrigens direkt den perfekten
geschenk tipp für sie ein e auto ja wer
seinen liebsten wirklich liebt stellt
ihnen ein e-auto unter den baum e autos
boom gerade wie blöde in deutschland
sind klar wegen der hohen benzinpreise
und wegen der fetten staatsknete die man
und ob geschenkt kriegt endlich
entdecken die deutschen ihre liebe zum
auto wissen sie noch wie das früher war
bei automessen war wurden die schweren
verbrenner immer total aufwendig und
liebevoll präsentiert und die e-autos
naja
wie sich die zeiten ändern heute ist das
e auto plötzlich sexy und der verbrenner
wird zum ladenhüter bei der
klimakonferenz in glasgow haben sich 24
staaten plus ein paar autokonzerne
verpflichtet den verbrenner bis 2040
weltweit zu verabschieden so findet
unsere bundesregierung im prinzip total
super macht aber nicht mit ein
abschiedsgeschenk von andy scheuer denn
glasgow einmal mehr als motor theresa
der autoindustrie aufgetreten ist aber
das sind nur peinliche rückzugsgefechte
der eu ist gar nicht mehr aufzuhalten
seit juli 2021 sind laut bundesregierung
über eine million stromer in deutschland
unterwegs zum ersten mal wurden mehr
elektro als diese neu zugelassen warum
spricht sie als wäre sie selber an eine
ladesäule angeschlossen
ich weiß es nicht alle wollen eine e
auto und am besten auch gleich ihre
eigene stromtankstelle in der garage die
sogenannte wall box
kleiner haken die nachfrage ist wohl ein
mythos
hier von der seite der staatlichen
kfw-bank bitte keine anträge mehr
stellen die fördermittel sind erschöpft
mit andern worten wir sind pleite kauf
gefälligst wieder diesel es ist ein
echtes problem wenn jetzt jeder jeder
von uns einen privaten schnell ader für
seine auto haben will dann rechnen
experten mit enormen lastspitzen im
deutschen netz hier der passende sat
1-film
sie fährt einen geilen elektro porsche
mit 600 ps ihr nachbar einen suv dessen
batterie mehr wiegt als ein pottwal weil
ihm das klima wichtig ist sie wohnen in
derselben stadt in derselben straße und
sie wollen das unmögliche
gleichzeitig ihre dreckskerl bleiben
doch sie haben die rechnung ohne das
deutsche stromnetz gemacht dass
deutschland ladesäulen massaker
sehen sie ryan gosling als neue
verkehrsminister robert habeck claude
oliver rudolph als die la mosca und
veronica ferres als kaputte ladesäule
wildeshausen dass deutschland ladesäule
masaka denn ihr könnt nicht einfache
laden von ihr wollt aber
[Applaus]
das schon so in manchen straßen darf nur
eine bestimmte zahl von wall boxen
hängen sonst heißt es entweder föhnen
oder auto laden ist und auf dem
boomenden automarkt tobt derweil der
kampf der giganten kessler gegen vw elon
musk versus herbert diess oder wir
offiziell genannt werden muss der techno
king auf tesla hat neulich den
börsenwert seiner auto klitsche auf mehr
als eine billion dollar gesteigert
herbert dagegen ist halt ein herbert
wäre aber auch gerne cool die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
inzwischen autostadt und kraftwerk und
möchte mich ganz herzlich bedanken für
sehen sie jetzt in letzter zeit ja
scheiße auf kalifornien in das malibu
die wirklich harten jungs surfen in
wolfsburg in crazy fucking wolfsburg ja
wo denn sonst wo denn sonst in wolfsburg
wo er dies neulich im aufsichtsrat
gangster style gedroppt hat man müssen
sich vielleicht mal von 30.000
mitarbeitern trennen da war wohl ein
missverständnis
e.on dagegen dieser ja visionäre
unternehmer guru baut seine teslas der
baut seine teslas schon bald im neuen
giga werk in brandenburg wo ihm die
landesregierung weiter jeden wunsch von
den augen abliest oder wie ion sagen
würde
bzw nein man kann über deutschland
wirklich alles mögliche sagen aber hier
noch gar nicht wirklich
kann da ja nicht wissen andererseits hat
der mann seine factory da auf dem
brandenburger gutenacker in nicht mal
zwei jahren aus dem boden gestampft
wow wie geht das also für uns gar nicht
aber als elon musk schreibst du einfach
einen brief an deutschland
tesla brandenburg schlägt daher
respektvoll vor dass die bundesrepublik
deutschland die grundlegenden änderungen
an den einschlägigen genehmigungs und
raumordnung sowie planungs gesetzen und
verfahren unverzüglich vornimmt und
deutschland so zu befehlen jawoll
unverzüglich
natürlich melden sich hier auch immer
wieder miesepeter zu wort und sagen
tesla ist an der börse total
überbewertet das servicenetz in
deutschland unzureichend und die
verarbeitungsqualität für sonn eures
auto also
da klappert halt mal was beim fahren
aber dann macht der tesla von alleine
das radio lauter ja
angeblich stellen sich vor braucht maske
für brandenburg noch 12.000 mitarbeiter
so viele menschen wohnen gar nicht in
brandenburg er twittert auf deutsch
bitte arbeiten sie bei tesla giga berlin
es wird super spaß machen ein super spaß
natürlich tesla arbeiter aus den usa
berichten zb von bis zu 50 überstunden
nur zwei wochen spaßiger geht's ja wohl
gar nicht gernot hassknecht jedenfalls
ist großer fan
gernot hassknecht wird der reichste mann
der welt
ganz genau ich würde reicher als gott
mit einem wasserdichten plan direkt
neben e.on speaker factory habe ich hier
die gernot fabrik hochgezogen und bald
geht das baby hier vom band money drei
bike deutschlands erstes elektrisches
drei haben
scheiße
dass die drei bike ich habe die
elektrische dreirad mobilität völlig neu
gedacht schon in wenigen jahren wird
jedes kleinkind ohne i3 bike im
kindergarten ausgelacht und verprügelt
aber was ist das geheimnis meines
baldigen reichtums ganz einfach ich will
alles was ihr macht klebt zum beispiel
subventionen von eu bund und land in
höhe von
1,4 milliarden euro
will ich gar nicht ich bin nicht gierig
ich will auch mitten im
wasserschutzgebiet
abwasserleitungen verlegen ohne
baugenehmigung und wenn sie jetzt sagen
dass ich ja auch nicht machen bei einem
reihenhaus sage ich halt die
freizeitoase du bist ja auch kein
milliardär
außerdem gibt es bei mir genau wie bei
tesla keinen betriebsrat gute vielleicht
meckert dann irgendwo verdi heini aber
dann sage ich
[Gelächter]
und jetzt als deutscher allen machst
zahle ich übrigens auch keine steuern
mehr bernie sanders dieser statistische
us senator hat gerade auf twitter
gefordert die reichsten menschen könnten
doch zitat langsam auch mal ihren teil
beitragen worauf ihren sauber kontert
ich vergesse immer dass du noch lebst
das hier ist die zukunft freunde der
dreirädrigen fortbewegung unser
basismodell gibt schon ab
27.000 euro ich muss mal klappt sein und
ab geht die wilde fahrt
statt mit batterie
das war schade gernot hassknecht wird
doch nicht der reichste mann der welt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbol ihr bei uns im neuen studio
gefunden illuminati freimaurer
staatsführung ist alles dabei dann
wollen wir denn die eigentlichen
strippenzieher bekanntgeben
er ist nicht so viele abonnenten auf
youtube
also ich würde mich ran halten